(audience clapping)
- Well, I've come with a bit of bad news.
As you know, everyone here
has been tested for COVID.
But unfortunately, some of
the test results have gotten lost.
So before we go on with the show,
we just have to do some quick
emergency testing backstage.
Don't worry, it's only a few
people, it' totally random.
So when I call your name,
I'm just gonna need you to come with me.
(audience laughs)
Now, I've got a list here,
which I'm looking at, I
have it memorized, but.
If you hear your name,
I'm gonna start with Bradley Cooper.
Timothy Chalamet, Tyler Perry, Simu Liu.
And wait, Javier Bardem, oh,
you're still with Penelope.
You know what, actually?
No, no, no, your test is fine.
It says that you're
married, negative, negative.
(audience laughs)
Will Smith, you're
married, but you know what?
You're on the list, and it
looks like Jada approved you.
So you get on up here, get on up here.
All right, now I see we've got
another bad boy on our list.
Let's see, is that Jacob Elordi?
Is that how you say it, Elordi?
I've seen you on "Euphoria"
and yes, you are legal.
I'm sorry, you are positive.
So you're gonna need a
deep PCR test, now...
(audience laughs)
No, no, I don't want any
you all to worry, you know?
It's gonna be a typical, quick COVID test.
You'll come back stage take your mask off,
if you have one, and your
clothes, and then I'm gonna swab.
(audience laughs)
No, it's simple.
I'm gonna swab the back of your
mouth with my tongue and...
(audience laughs)
We're just gonna do
some other freaky stuff,
which I will record for Academy protocol.
Really, this isn't up to me.
You know, the truth is,
we're still in a pandemic.
(audience laughs)
Oh boy, one more name on the list.
So Denzel, Pauletta, is John David here?
No, no.
(audience laughs)
I'll make a house call, it's
fine, there's no need to worry.
There will be more names.
I'll see you guys at the back
in backstage but right now...
You can go back there,
I'll be waiting for you.
Please welcome Jason
Mamoa and Josh Brolin.
(audience cheers)